welcome to this video this is yet
another video featuring one of my games
from the bud we say open tournament to
open bavarian championships yeah this is
Ronald seven and after six rounds I had
4.5 points yeah losing one game against
Landerman and conceding a draw to number
one seed ml kumi on so not a bad
tournament I beat or the other rating
wise weaker players and ya still there
were no chances left to score
Grandmaster know the only thing left was
trying form one of the the main prices
um and this term basically means that
you need seven points okay quick
calculation three rounds left means two
and a half points out of three is the
the goal on at least 2.5 two and a half
points but well three out of three years
a little bit optimistic so in round
seven I got white against a Bavarian
feed master Ludwick Dickerman pretty
dangerous player he had beaten um
Grandmaster del chef very strong 2600 GM
earlier in the tournament and I had
white so it was clear this is one of
those games that you basically need to
win if you want one of the main prizes
so let's see what happens i play deform
and the reason for that is that I saw my
opponent plays the Dutch defense quite
often somehow the Dutch defense or f4
played an important role in this
tournament yeah and I wanted to play
after f5 he didn't do that but I wanted
to go Knight c3 sm i did in my game in
round two so this is why i started d for
not 93 to get this specific line however
he played Knight f6 okay not a surprise
he had done this before c4 and now he
played Knight to c6 okay this was a
surprise
this opening the the two nights tango or
black knights tangle defense did not yet
happen in his games I learned later that
he had played it in one of the earlier
rounds but it wasn't a game that was the
beater or in any way available to me so
it really came as a surprise however um
I wasn't it wasn't really am yeah upset
or irritated because I have some
knowledge because I have played this
opening myself as black and let's in
fact one possibility that I gladly took
now played Knight f3 e6 this is how
black his son playing at 93 yeah Knight
c3 basically forces black to play Bishop
to b4 and after Quincy to ya Bishop to
b4 is false because I'm threatening
afore he cannot allow that so be sure
before and now Queen c2 yeah and what we
have now is we have a Zurich Zurich line
of the classical names oh yeah what I'm
talking about is the normal move order
is like that Quincy 296 93 and if you
watch my blitz games sometimes or
regularly you know that this is what I
do is black against the nim zone and
also a line featured in my book so I
didn't mind to play this right honey I
have some knowledge about it obviously
so why not play it with the white pieces
and it's a the kind of position that you
get that you can easily play from both
sides which is complex and interesting
okay and also my suspicion was that he
is new to the opening and probably will
not know all the details and this in
fact turned out to be true d6 Bishop g5
h6 Bishop b2 yeah this looks a bit
curious why Bishop g5 and after age 60
up back yeah black really cannot do
without age 6
the long run this penis is annoying and
it's the case where after age six white
cannot really play this as this is
blundering a porn on your phone so I
have to go back but why it would wide
lose a temple like that it is in fact an
advantage for white to have the porn on
age six why will become apparent in the
course of the game it is however pretty
subtle point that is not very often
recognized and then chest literature or
comments on games but we will see and
we'll see why h6 is something that white
likes to see ya castles when a three
takes takes Queen e7 yeah what black is
doing is he's going for a five a pretty
common strategy if you have seen my game
against Landerman in round six you will
notice that black setup is pretty much
identical the simple is very similar to
what I had against Landerman we only had
a different minor beats distribution but
blacks plan is essentially the same you
trade the dark squared bishop and then
set up a five to get a good bishop from
a structural point of view yeah I know
went before expanding on the on the
queenside and he played a 5d 59 to be 8
and e4 yeah this is what I believe to be
the most testing line for white against
this opening it is basically the main
line of my section in the upcoming book
on the Zurich defense on the names oh
yeah and actually my main move here that
i will recommend in my book i can tell
you this right away is a 5 you're
setting up some counter play on the
queenside a while counter place may be
the wrong word but it is a way to
activate the rukon aid which is some is
a little bit stuck this rook and with a
5 you
um yeah you make sure that it has some
use um however he didn't play that he
played the move Knight aged 5 and this
is in a way and the most natural move in
the position because black ones counter
plane f5 black need some sort of palm
break if he is just sitting around and
doing nothing he will be worse because
of the space disadvantage and the breaks
that he has a b5 very unlikely to manage
sometimes possible c6 and f5 yeah f5 is
the most obvious one and very often the
right idea in fact the move Knight h5 is
the move that is played mostly and
justifiably so in the same position with
the pond back on 87 the reason why it is
not so good here is the move g3 and the
the big problem is that now like cannot
play at five after f5 I play night h4
and here we see the big point of white
provoking age 6 yeah I know it has been
eight moves ago that this provocation
happened but this is really the big
subtle point now f5 is a lot more
difficult to achieve and in this case
even impossible if we look at something
like this for example after he takes
Bishop takes Knight takes and this whole
line of trades white in fact already
wins with the move f4 yeah pretty pretty
funny move after the capture does G for
winning a piece note that the media g4
can be answered by ruga three funny
counter-attack yeah this is a line that
that than you of course because I had
invested hours for my book but the
problem for him was he had to find all
that over the board and by this point g3
we had a funny situation
in terms of clock times we had this 90
minutes as a starting starting time and
then 30 second increment and at this
point I had 95 minutes on my clock so I
gained five minutes because I could
basically blitz all the moves and um
yeah I mean I know I knew what I was
doing and he had to basically reinvent
the wheel over the board and he was down
to 25 minutes by this point or 30
minutes I don't write down the clock
times normally but it was something like
that very very clear advantage in time
that I had after longer consideration he
came up with a 5 which is a think a
pretty good solution and it's quite
comparable to my a5 suggestion one move
earlier basically in the game what he
gets a slightly worse version of my my
analysis where the moves g3 and night h5
are not played frankly this is not
happening him a lot the night on age 5
because he can never play a five and and
therefore it's a slightly a slightly
worse version of of what I think is best
for black however it is not that
terrible blacks position is still fairly
solid in fact my next move is probably
not so precise I now played the move
Bishop to e2 and intending to go night
age for using this offside position of
the night and I underestimated the
upcoming sequence to be honest and
especially a 1-1 line I'm I think with
hindsight it was better to play Bishop
g2 and make sure that Bishop h3 is not
coming after that we probably get
something like this and from here we
continue with a no tonight a 6 did the
scan of line with white maybe being a
little bit better after Bishop g4 I go
to d2 not allowing any trades and again
he cannot play a 5 due to his somewhat
weird piece construction here um this is
what I should have done however I played
Bishop e2 and will show you what I had
yeah misjudged in a way he now it took
took on a 1 and played Bishop 83 kind of
normal in this in this line yeah the
thing is what I did not really
appreciate much is the following
sequence night h4 this is what I played
and is right this is the right
continuation night f4 funny reply but
the only one that that really makes any
sense and here I originally thought that
Bishop f1 would be quite nice yeah the
idea is that if he now takes I get in
night f5 with the with a nice position
however what I did not really appreciate
before this that well he does not need
to take he can also just play a
developing like 97 and after that they
have a really weird construction on the
Kings side I don't want to take on f4
damaging my structure and I really don't
know what kind of useful moves i should
play i can play the bishop over here but
he also has ruka aid with a with a
useful idea to invade on the a file very
difficult to get my rook into play here
and something like that um yeah I mean
still I cannot cancel I am Not sure I
mean I was really irritated that this
wasn't working so I went with Bishop e3
which is not bad I mean I'm not saying
why this verse or anything but I really
thought I should get some advantage out
of the opening but it's not it's not
really the case if he continues
precisely black is still quite okay he
now went to g6
and I played 95 the reason why black is
quite playable is simply the out of play
Rukia yeah the bishop p.m. controlling
this means i have a hard time to castle
and get the routine to play yeah he went
to d7 I was more expecting Queen d8 but
it's not not really bad and here played
bishops III yeah the whole position I
mean looks nice for white I have more
space i have two bishops but still
without the rook it's difficult and he
played it well he played c6 which is a
good idea you need to open the position
a bit as black getting some counter play
here on the C file yeah well here I
played 93 I think this is the best move
taking on c6 this kind of thing it looks
interesting at first because of the
pressure on d6 but black has interesting
counter play by means of 94 something
like that for example is totally unclear
i'm still playing without my king yeah i
think bishop sorry 93 is what I play
this is I think a good move the night is
not doing that much on f5 anyway and
after 93 I had envisioned this
structural change already he took here
and now i have night c4 as a possibility
in the future yeah look c8 this is all I
think very logical yeah here you can
maybe debate what white should do but i
think my move king d 2 is quite quite ok
i need to get the rook into the game and
well the King on d 2 is a safe peace
yeah here he went night a 6 plate queen
d three ad before was hanging so and he
went nighty 7 I think this is all
logical from both sides and
uh it's while you can suggest other
things it's not something that you can
criticize much hope late Bishop e2 also
I think a good move getting this Bishop
on a better diagonal and helping to
prepare moves like 94 or also Queen B 5
Queen B 5 note that one thing I in my
favor is that in a possible endgame
mcqueen's are traded my king is already
active and near the queenside may be
ready to join oops I didn't want to play
at five year and he of course didn't
play it in the game ya ready to join the
action on the queenside yeah he now
played the Moose f5 maybe this is
questionable and you should try to UM
improve his pieces a little bit more but
I totally understand that he finally
wants to get in this break and he's an
active player he does not want to just
sit and wait however it seems that here
White has a pretty good continuation in
fact I saw the moose but I couldn't
really yeah it wasn't clear to me I
played f3 in the end but f4 f4 is the
move that I saw but I wasn't sure about
it is a very logical move because it
opens up my bishop here but I wasn't
sure because I thought that this line
here this and night f5 yeah I probably
have to trade takes Queen deform
whoopsies have grouped you when I had
seen this position and I was thinking
okay it looks like I should be better I
mean this and this it all looks nice but
he has g7 defended and well my pawn
structure is not great i only have
four pawns left and they're all isolated
and I wasn't really sure if this is so
great I mean I was thinking maybe he can
defend g7 and get his night improved and
hmm how exactly do i improve from here I
mean probably white is just a little bit
better in any case due to the two
bishops but um yeah I'm still unsure if
I should have done that to be honest
well I think my every move is not bad
but it is somewhat somewhat indecisive
you know it's a little bit of a half
moon um yeah he now plate 97 which is
good and I played rugae one yeah my rook
finally into play with the idea to maybe
use it on a cell phone and I think the
next move now is some is a real mistake
up to this point I think he played well
he now play drew k-8 what needs to be
mentioned is that at this point i still
had almost an hour left on the clock had
a huge advantage on the clock and he was
down to just a couple of minutes and
this is really an important factor to
have this pressure on the clock um yeah
well rook e8 was a smooth trying to
trade my my active looking look on a one
this however has a has a direct drawback
what he should do is to take only form F
takes ninety eight and ten dig Knight f6
and after that I think that black has
some reached a position where he can be
reasonably satisfied um I still think
that white is a very very little better
because I have ideas to play against the
d6 porn but we have a position where
there are no porn breaks left which
favours the Knights in general and he
had does not have any bad pieces like a
dark squared Bishop would be awful on f8
or something so this is okay yeah I
didn't I didn't mind to play this
position as why
but it should be should be playable for
black and it best be a little bit worse
um yeah he went with luca age but this
is really a mistake and the reason is
the following I can take and I did take
night takes and here white has a choice
I still have F 444 good play but i also
have g4 and this is what i played this
is now i'm hitting black in a very
unlucky moment as she fumbles it
isolates the bishop and this is a big
problem the bishop is offside this idea
always was in the position for the last
couple of moves but now with the night
being on a a this is especially
problematic now he only has one
continuation and this is also what i
thought in the in the game he has to
take on g4 now it's absolutely the only
move something like this is really
almost losing the bishop on the long run
very very difficult to play if at all
yeah you should take and I recapture and
now my idea is to play Knight f5 yeah
with a discovered attack on the bishop
black still can can play this but it is
very tough very tough to defend um the
point is that I play they should play
this to play night f4 and now after
night f5 Bishop g2 um I have to move
Queen B 5 I had seen this in the game um
and thought that ok white is better here
how much it's hard to tell the reason
why what is better is that something
like this wins the d6 porn and we get a
get a very open position now something
like Bishop t5p should be three night
has to move and after Bishop be one I
will take on e5 next and here we have a
position where white has the bishop pair
in a wide open situation my king is
better and his King is still on g8 a
very very uncomfortable
for black to the event you know I I
think that that's very tough to play
very tough to play this is just one
possibility but I had seen the start of
this line and thought okay well this is
nice let's go for it however after
g-form jump back to the key position
here as mentioned he didn't have much
time and was just a couple of minutes
left on the clock he took on e4 um I
think this is just something of a
blackout I think he basically thought
that it was it doesn't didn't matter
much how he takes as I recapture with
the pawn however after F takes e4 I have
the additional idea to take with the
Queen and this is much much better in
comparison to have the Queen only for ya
this position is really directly lost
for black I mean like totally lost he
has absolutely no defense against the
duel ideas of Bishop d3 and tweenage 7 +
f4 which opens up here and then Queenie
r34 this is very very colorful um let's
have a look at the variegation he went
Knight b6 yeah but let's say he plays a
move like this then I have this idea and
now Queen g3 or queen f3 basically wins
the bishop it is trapped and after f4
also note that this long diagonal opens
up yeah he he played in the game he
played night to be 6 click Bishop d3
threatening to enter here with decisive
effect so d6 and now I played f4 and
yeah this position is it's like it's
totally winning for white and it was a
bit surprised so that he already
resigned him it is justified but still I
expected some sort of move to be played
it is however impossible to find
something that is even remotely playable
for example after Bishop takes g4 I take
on e5 and after Bishop f5 queen d 4 wide
wings on the
long diagonal like this for example and
this is going to be a checkmate soon
yeah after f4 as mentioned here him he
resigned there is really no playable
move it was very surprised how quickly
this went this went downhill after the f
takes e4 capture but this is what very
often happens in in games where there is
not that much happening but when there
is a huge clock um disadvantage for one
side very often you don't have the time
to to to think about the subtle points
and sometimes you overlook those simple
things where you think okay let's just
take there and it's not you don't have
the time to check and you think okay it
doesn't matter i just take here whatever
and then you all of a sudden recognize
oh no it can take with the Queen so it's
something that can can easily happen
yeah I think it was an interesting an
interesting game where he defended very
well after this problem in the opening
way he had this huge disadvantage on the
clock on a position like like here or
after after the capture on e4 with 98 is
definitely okay for black but at the end
the the time problem really am was was
very much very much important and this
netted me a win so a very nice win in
this round seven keeping me in
contention for one of the main prizes
we're not talking about about a huge
sums of money here but if we M something
like seven points probably Nets you like
three or four hundred euros of things go
well okay yeah thanks for watching this
game i hope you enjoyed it